Повністю відмовитися від використання вугілля в енергетиці до 2035 року -
таку обіцянку Україна дала на кліматичній конференції в Глазго.
Це означає, що нових ТЕС чи шахт більше не будуватимуть, а старі державні потужності поступово закриватимуться.
Вугільна промисловість в Україні - це 33 державні шахти.
Проте вони видобувають лише 30 відсотків від загального виробництва вугілля.
Решта підприємств - приватні. Найбільше шахт має компанія Ріната Ахметова “ДТЕК”.
Через військову агресію Росії в самопроголошених республіках “ДНР” і “ЛНР” залишилися шахти,
які до 2014 року давали половину українського вугілля.
Після видобутку вугілля постачається на державні або приватні теплоелектростанції.
Оксана Алієва, керівниця програм про зміни клімату і енергетику в київському офісі німецького Фонду імені Гайнріха Бьолля,
розмовляє з DW, щойно повернувшись із Глазго.
Пояснює - 2035 рік - це дедлайн для державного сектору, але не для приватного.
Тут треба також подивитися, що це саме на державних підприємствах, тобто на вугільних ТЕС.
Паралельно з цим, до цього самого безвугільного альянсу долучилася наприклад компанія ДТЕК,
яка володіє значно більшою часткою вугільної теплової генерації в Україні в порівнянні з державними компаніями
і заявила дату відмови - 2040 рік.
Метою відмови від вугілля, заявленої в Глазго, є опіка про довкілля, адже викиди від вугільних підприємств - серед основних причин зміни клімату.
Водночас Київ має і інші причини поступово відходити від вугілля.
За оцінками Міненерго, із трьох десятків державних шахт рентабельними є тільки кілька.
На решту держава щороку витрачає понад 5 млрд гривень на рік,
аби лише підтримувати їхнє існування і виплачувати борги шахтарям.
Якщо поступово не закривати такі шахти, то, за оцінками аналітиків,
в наступне десятиліття доведеться витратити ще 710 мільйонів євро на підтримку галузі.
Тож перехід на зелену енергетику, хоч і вимагає значних інвестицій на початку,
все одно економічно вигідніший шлях, кажуть експерти.
Дослідження показують, такий енергоперехід буде дешевшим на 400 мільйонів євро в наступні 10 років, якщо робити його поступово і планово.
Ще однією причиною, на тлі якої Україна пообіцяла відмовитися від вугілля, стала цьогорічна криза із дефіцитом вугілля.
23 енергоблоки українських ТЕС зупинилися перед самим початком опалювального сезону через брак вугілля на складах.
Тобто з одного боку, добувати своє вугілля невигідно,
а з іншого - самостійно виробити 15 млн тонн вугілля, які необхідні ТЕС для проходження зими, Україна не може.
Декларація в Глазго зобов'язує країни не лише скоротити виробництво електроенергії з вугілля,
а й розвивати натомість відновлювану енергетику.
Тож просто замінити вугілля на газ чи атом не вийде.
15 енергоблоків на АЕС, якими володіє Україна, не можуть так легко маневрувати збільшуючи або зменшуючи потужності,
а будувати нові атомні реактори ще більш не вигідно, ніж шукати інвестування для “зеленої енергетики”.
Згідно із моделюванням міжнародних, в тому числі німецьких аналітиків,
сукупні інвестиції у нові потужності повинні становити 28 мільярдів євро до 2030 року.
Це дуже велика сума, треба розуміти, що це не гроші, які треба знайти за один рік.
Ці 28 мільярдів євро, які необхідні на нові технології, це не мають бути кошти з державного бюджету,
це мають бути кошти приватних інвесторів, які зацікавлені інвестувати в енергетику.
Оксана Алієва запевняє: якщо спочатку держава вкладе свої кошти і створить чіткі механізми в галузі,
то решта знайдеться з міжнародних програм протидії зміні клімату.
Створення Зеленого фонду на суму не менше, ніж один мільярд доларів пообіцяли, зокрема, Анґела Меркель і Джо Байден тоді,
коли йшлося про компенсацію Україні за збитки через запуск “Північного потоку-2”.
За задумом, Німеччина спочатку має додати до фонду не менше, ніж 175 мільйонів доларів в якості гранту.
Обіцянка відмовитися від вугілля до 2035 року наразі є лише оголошенням намірів.
Ані штрафних санкцій за невиконання, ані хоча б міжнародної комісії, яка б контролювала такі процеси в різних країнах, не передбачено.
Це просто красива заява українського уряду.
І надалі ця дата повинна бути закріплена в національних документах, щоби національна політика формувалася з урахуванням цієї дати.
Ухвалення державних документів про відмову від вугілля, ймовірно, наштовхнеться на чималий спротив.
З одного боку. проти буде вугільне лобі, тобто великі гравці ринку, хоча в заяві у Глазго йшлося наразі лише про державну енергетику, а не приватну.
А з іншого боку, проти можуть бути шахтарські профспілки і цілі міста, залежні від вугілля.
У нас є 33 державних шахти, на яких працює приблизно 36 тисяч людей - це працівники,
а в кожного шахтаря є дружина, діти, батько, мати, тобто ці 36 тисяч одразу стають 100 тисячами.
Це люди, сім'я яких повністю залежна від вугілля.
Мирноград, Добропілля, Нью Йорк, Покровськ і ще п'ять міст на Донеччині у травні 2019 зрозуміли,
що лінія зіткнення із російською агресію - не єдиний виклик, який найближчим часом може знищити їхні міста.
Світова тенденція до зменшення викидів від вугілля, за рахунок яких існують усі їхні міста, створює неминучість закриття копалень.
Ці міста об'єдналися в Платформу сталого розвитку вугільних міст
і створюють технопарки, об'єкти зеленої енергетики або туристичні маршрути на території шахт.
Таким чином шахтарські міста почали готуватися до вугільної незалежності ще до того, як цей курс обрала Україна.